[ __ ] didly didly better use American
ingenuity
most of these [ __ ] have
forgotten about
you have to go the internet I could
build the house with duct tape three
joints if you will and I wonder what you
say and I wonder what you do so let me
start by saying I love
[Laughter]
you gotta loosen up the phlegm when
you're about inhale the [ __ ] smoke of
debt it's the afternoon sunny California
I'm hearing my main man Lisa at with
chill in the backyard get a little
[ __ ] vitamin D and getting some
vitamin G green [ __ ] reefer
tremendous smoking weed like Pablo
[ __ ] Escobar an episode 2 season
2
that's how we do it if you ain't smoking
reefer like Pablo quit right now you're
just lying to yourself and you're lying
to all this you understand a couple
different reefers today we're smoking
this last batch of the [ __ ] tightened
from button roses always throwing Heat I
got a little [ __ ] vegan ik og one of
the [ __ ] that means
and I got some of this blueberry charade
here from Prince this these wank princes
[ __ ] dust [ __ ] from his house or
some [ __ ] and that's it you guys are
expecting all much more than that this
is just the family sitting down smoking
a few Blanc bones and getting that [ __ ]
together that's it that's all this is
this ain't no big deal this ain't a show
this ain't nothing
this is too [ __ ] animals getting
together in the afternoon
beautiful ooh you little [ __ ]
tremendous you Jewish Jesus Christ oh
it's nice to be able to do this with
family who else could [ __ ] smoke with
his family every day and go listen we're
having a good [ __ ] time that's us
that's what we do that's it there's no
drama here there's nothing I'm gonna
have my celebrity buddy who needs these
[ __ ] people
it's just lost Lisa at entraining us
that's it
oh these [ __ ] amateurs want to show
you they smoke so long I'm like [ __ ]
you know by myself that's the best way
to get hired up to get any and beaten
people breathing on me and [ __ ] you know
I said that's it don't be [ __ ] do
which and you want to know he won't try
the other one was the vegan ik I like
you like it
no that was the blueberry okay we'll try
the veganic in the second here we live
more [ __ ] weed I'm not a week I just
went yesterday two days ago an 8 and 2
grams subscribing to have grams in the
day
who the [ __ ] smokes this type of [ __ ]
[Music]
hey Robert he's back in rehab I can stop
smoking reefer - I just wish that what
you don't say who needs to smoke when
I'm eating [ __ ] 33,000 milligrams
you always gotta give a little reader if
not the whole [ __ ] reefer unit and
you know just what to say and you know
just what to do Isis comes will be in
[ __ ] tip-top shape he could smoke
with anybody understand and he [ __ ]
him body
you bet those people get fake I should
they close their eyes and me believe it
I'm really stoned dude the [ __ ] out of
here
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you and the horse you rode
up on it I'm saying his uncle Joey's
world [ __ ] get it together
Thursday night flappers 9:30 Friday 8
o'clock
Melrose Improv Saturday 8:00 o'clock
Melrose impre next Thursday the party
starts at Austin with lee-sia
and the Friday after that whenever I see
[ __ ] so sharpen your dick and get
that Vaseline ready it's over this is
the veganic doing some funcle' Joey and
that's all that matters I got this -
from bud and roses when you go on ahead
tom you want the [ __ ] tighten uncle
Joey said give me the [ __ ] tighten
not the Tennessee Titan [ __ ] those
[ __ ]
you want the high ten that's it [ __ ]
so I said and that's that what else you
want from me I'm [ __ ] stoned what else
do you expect
you didn't come on here and smoke the
world's best weed and just flop no with
a stone to the gills
five grand
know what I went to a weed store Sunday
because Tuesday yes that I'm gonna we do
it today no I went yesterday yeah this
is I can't do this move stop I can't
stop smoking please help me I can't stop
I can't stop smoking and drinking monkey
idols from Starbucks go get it together
[Music]
there you go just like that should we do
one wrong what do you think we can have
we can have a vegan ik we'll do half and
half and call it a [ __ ] day I'll see
you guys later we'll be at the Dark
Horse saloon tonight and Reseda Lee goes
on stage on Tuesday night we go update a
few muscles somebody always brings a
joint you know how that goes s'mores
with luck it not what are they are
waffles they make s'mores and [ __ ]
waffles it's a bad situation but
somebody's
Oh nobody's getting their feelings hurt
this what it's all about hanging out
with family smoking a bowl when you're
going you [ __ ] marry way this is it
everybody wants to hang out and do this
but some guy today I can't wait to hang
up and be all intellectual guess what
[ __ ] is Uncle Joe ain't no intellectual
that's not my [ __ ] game so that's it
I'm I'm well we came out here we joined
you we fixed the [ __ ] periscope and
now guess what it's all about you see
you tomorrow at the church
[Music]